[Music]
as dawn breaks over a moveable city of
10,000 yachts queen Bachchan is in for a
rude awakening
a rogue sheep has slipped past her
servants and guards and bolted into her
yet where he springs into bed and bleeps
in her air although she's a formidable
katana of the golden horde a huge
Kingdom in the Mongolian Empire brockton
has a hands-on approach to ruling she's
been married to bar to Khan the fearsome
grandson of Genghis Khan himself since
she was 15 and while her husband is out
on his raids she juggles the duties of
flocks family and Empire at home this
makes her the manager and the mover of a
city of thousands twice a year bachchan
moves the city between two seasonal
camping grounds this ensures constant
water and lush grass in summer and
protection from harsh winds in winter
the whole operation requires weeks of
strict planning lazing with other camps
in her domain strategic delegation and
the patience to move at the speed of
dawdling animals today is moving day and
she'll have to direct throngs of her
ladies commanders slaves and animals up
the river Volga for the summer as
Brockton steps outside she's greeted by
a commotion her unwanted visitor is now
running circles around her stewards they
are attempting to stow her possessions
securely into wagons barchan orders them
to get it under control but she's the
only one quick enough to catch the stray
she next supervises her ladies who are
unpinning her yet and lifting it onto
its custom Wiegand it requires a team of
20 oxen to pull amber action wouldn't
trust anyone to steer it but herself
next Bracton and her woolly companion
meet with the guards she ordered them to
keep close watch on her husband special
reception yet and portable throne during
the journey they'll also act as
outriders and she tells them how to
secure the route surround her for safety
and keep the animals in check but when
the Sheep finally breaks free and makes
for the fields the guard can barely keep
up as its campers through crowds packing
up their yurts exasperated Bracton rides
down to the pastures herself when she
gets there she catches sight of the
troublesome sheep wriggling into the
middle of a flock when she follows him
in he's nestled next to her you his
mother she's pregnant and seems to be in
pain with a start brockton realizes that
this use impending delivery has been
forgotten in the flurry of moving day
there's no time to find a shepherd
instead borrachón rolls up her sleeves
greases her arm and helps the you give
birth to two new additions to the Empire
leaving the Lambs and their mother for
action dashes back to the camp here the
final touches have been put to packing
and vehicles are starting to line up
this vast procession starts with the
Queen and two hundred wagons filled with
her treasures next up are the junior
wives and crew then the concubines and
this is only Bachchan's camp after this
comes the second imperial camp led by
another senior wife then two more camps
also led by wives brockton has been
checking in with them for weeks to
ensure a smooth departure and orderly
queue but they only make up the royal
portion of the line behind them wins the
entire civilian City which includes holy
men with portable chapels and mosques
families tradesman and shepherds finally
borrachón settles into her wagon it'll
take weeks to reach their destination
but over the course of the journey
she'll keep everyone expertly in check
from her proud children and attentive
subjects to the most meandering sheep at
the back of the line
[Music]
want to know more about Bachchan's
husband's grandfather learn more with
this lesson on history versus Genghis
Khan
[Music]